[音楽]
voodoo
[拍手]
みなさんは自分の馬猫今日が過疎化や少子高齢化でいつか寂れていくかもしれないと
いうことを想像したことはありますか
もしそうなったら寂しいなという気持ちになるのではないでしょうか
今日は私のうまねこ今日である山間の街を元気づけるために行った
小さなアイディアについてお話しします
浜私に佐川町という地域があります
浜松駅から60キロほど北上した愛知や中野との県境にする地域です
私はその作画に会える浜松工工工左官分校の会9分に所属し
マネージャーとして選手の練習のサポートをしています
さて皆さんは策もに対してどのようなイメージを持っているでしょうか
最高気温が高い地域として名前を聞く人もいるでしょう
塩の高さは厚され電車が遅延してしまうほどです
車かまわかのような豊かな自然に囲まれ
sa 造物も活発に活動しています
日常生活の中で鹿や猿
猪うさぎらのの生き物に遭遇することもあります
夏には彼はが私たちの最高の遊び場くなります
私はこの佐久間に住んでいることを誇りに思っています
しかし自然に囲まれている佐久間ならではの問題もあります
電車はさあ時間に1本しか来ない時もあり最寄りのコンビニは車で20分先にあります
毎年地域内の店も少しずつ少なくなっており
最近では行きつけの書店もお店を畳んでしまいました
100万は山間地域です
市が中心部から遠距離にあり人口流出
少子化高齢化が著しく家族地域に定められてしまいました
沢山の自然に囲まれている代わりに無視できない側面も抱えています
そんな佐久間にある唯一の高校が坂は分校です
ちょうど私が入学生時に尺間高校から
尺間部壕へと変わりました
全校生徒は69人ととても少ないですが1人ひとりがそれぞれに彼が行ける学校だと
思っています
でも分校というとあまりいい印象はないかもしれません
例えば佐久間の隣町である愛知県の高校は分校化してから3年で廃校となってしまい
ました
近くの地域でそのようなことがあったので
尺まり唯一の高校が分校化することに対して地域の人も寂しさを感じているようにも
見えました
その様な状況の中で佐久間部校野球部は元気のなくなった地域を盛り上げたいと考え
ました
高校野球は夏の選手権大会で勝つと校歌を歌うことができます
そこで夏の大会でたくさんの人に校歌を歌ってもらうことができるようにと選手は日々
冷静に取り組んでいます
私は静止のように直接グランドに立って相手コート戦うことはできないし
年使用して技術を習得し試合で活躍をするということもできません
しかし者石のように佐久間を盛り上げたいという気持ちは一緒です
私もマネージャーとして尺間を盛り上げるということに何か変わることはできないかと
考えました
私はまず地域地域の方と駅へ部がつながれるきっかけを作ろうと考えました
ak 部とでキューブが買って盛り上がってもらうにはまず
駅指について知ってもらうことが大事なのではないかと考え
通学路の商店街にカバーを設置しました
カバーに書く内容は試合の結果
学校で行う練習自演のお知らせ
選手の紹介などです
今の時代多くの人に情報を伝えるときには sns で拡散するのが一般的になってい
ます
しかし私がここで選んだのは看板を立てて情報を伝えるということでした
さ形への一つは地域には高齢者が多く
sns では伝わりにくいと思ったからです
その他にも手書きには温かみがあると思ったし
看板がおしゃべりの話題のひとつとなってくれたら嬉しいなと思ったからです
この看板は週に1度のペースで更新はしています
私は全く sns で情報を出していなかっ分でこの看板のことは佐久間に在住して
いる方にしか広まっていないと思っていましたが
看板を貸してもらっているお店の方が
更新をする事に sns に上げてくださっていました
そのおかげで自分の予想以上に異径部のことをたくさんの人に知ってもらうことができ
ました
関門を設置してさまざまな変化がありました
一番反響があったと感じるのは学校で行う
ecj のお知らせをしたことです
看板多く前にも試合の的に不安なに足を運んでくれる方が増えました
また看板を出した方により野球部に興味を持ってくれる人も増えました
看板を見るために焦点が家まで足を運んでくれる人もいたそうです
学校の通学路に設置したことにより
在校生や中学生もい警部のことに興味を持ってくれたようでした
たくさんの人ができ部のことに関心を持ってくれるようになったので清酒のみんなも
試合の結果にこだわるようになったようにも感じました
看板を設置してよかったことは他にも沢山あります
今年の夏の大会のことも緩慢で伝えました
無茶の大会は焼津球場で行われました
車釜から焼津まではとても遠く
また大雨の影響にように電車が止まり
使用道路も通行止めとなっていました
しかし球場のスタンドにはたくさんの地元の方が足を運んでくれていました
私はその試合でベンチに入っていたので試合中のスタンドの様子は分かりませんでした
が
試合終了後にスタンドを見るとたくさんの知っている顔で埋められていました
それを見た時にとても感動しました
今日本には少子高齢化が進行し過疎地域となってしまった
待ちや地域が増えています
そのような地域に人を戻すこと
昔のように社会ていた地域に戻すことは難しくかなわないかもしれません
しかしカンバー雪のような小さなお子の縁が地域の人々を元気づける
小さなきっかけとなるかもしれません
私はこの地域のつながりはこれからも大切にしていきたいと思っています
今後も異径部の妹を伝え続けていきます
[拍手]